they say that battle changes
it makes you stronger
are ferocious
a monster in the night watching
hunting
each time I enter the pit I emerge
reborn
put the devil on the other side and I
will show up involved
adapted
and prepared
to fight
hey youtubers is Charlie they just
dropped the injustice to trailer so this
is just a quick breakdown of what the
hell is going on it looks like everyone
just got beefed up for Justice League
fight night if you've never played it
injustice is kind of DC's version of a
mortal combat fight game with a lot of
mixed RPG elements so you got story mode
you got battle mode is pretty
self-explanatory
if you haven't played the newer Mortal
Kombat game look at the most recent
Mortal Kombat game it's actually pretty
fun as a pretty good story mode but is
part of this big injustice game DC
actually did a tie-in comic book series
is just called injustice gods among us
is this really dystopian take on the
characters so everybody is way more
hardcore everybody hates each other
it's like darkest timeline Justice
League if you remember earth-2 from the
flash season 2 this year it's kind of
like that it's almost like earth 3 from
the comics where everybody is a
supervillain so all the stuff that's
happening in the game is not canon to
the comics it's not happening on the TV
shows it's like its own self-contained
universe and they haven't announced
anything but because they did a big
comic book tie-in with the first run of
the game
they'll probably write a new story that
ties in with injustice 2 so it actually
looks pretty badass the biggest new
element here though is the playable
Supergirl character she wasn't a
playable character in the first game but
if you haven't played it yet it's pretty
much on every console you could possibly
imagine
they've only announced injustice 2 on
ps4 and Xbox one but it's a pretty safe
bet that it'll hit all consoles
eventually sometimes there's a console
exclusive window where it's only going
to be on Xbox and ps4 for like a week
before it gets released on PC so it's
not going to drop till next year so
there's plenty of time to figure that
stuff out but this Bryan Cranston Lex
Luthor Heisenberg voiceover it's just
meant to let you know that they're
upping the stakes is just getting way
crazier more playable characters and
they'll probably be some other crazy
tie-ins too usually when they release
sequel games instead of just adding
playable characters they try to change
the game in a meta way that makes it
feel like it's not just adding story on
to the first version of the game what
I'm expecting is is that there'll be
more playable characters than there were
when the first game was released if you
buy the game right away the other
characters will probably be DLC if or if
you get a season pass you'll get them
for free but if you wait you get the
ultimate Edition and you get everything
all at the same time so because the
first game has been out for so long you
don't have to why you can get all the
characters right now but let me know in
the comments
what did you guys think about the first
game I know I didn't do any gameplay or
any videos for that first game but if
you guys want I'll totally try and do
some videos for this one ever drops it
just it's gonna be so long before it
gets here
that we're really only going to be
getting more trailers for the rest of
the year some of you have asked I do
have a video game channel that's
separate from this it's just called
Charlie's streams
there's a link in the description for
that there's a link for my twitch
channel which is also just called
emergency awesome but here's a really
cool thing what I'm actually expecting
them to do is try and do some movie
tie-in content like some DLC some skins
they did that for Stephen Amell Zarrow
character whenever arrow drops so they
do special tie-in content for the TV
shows they will definitely do it for the
movies if you didn't follow the story of
the first injustice game and then like
that tie-in comics basically what
happens is is the Joker does something
crazy kills Lois Lane turns Superman
against humanity the Justice League
battles to take him down it turns into
this big conflict it's kind of like the
flash storyline flash point where the
Justice League winds up fighting
themselves is really dystopian they're
only able to stop evil Superman by
traveling the multiverse till they find
another version that will help them out
like a good version of Superman so I'm
curious to see what the story is for the
second game that ups the stakes so much
but just to be clear this is not canon
two what's going on in the comics right
now with rebirth it has absolutely
nothing to do with that it has nothing
to do with what's going on in the movies
or the TV shows this is a self-contained
story just like Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns it just kind of exists
off by itself I am gonna go ahead and
start a new round of the DC giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
I'll be talking about flash rebirth and
green arrow rebirth story stuff that's
happening tomorrow so if you guys
haven't read it be sure to check out the
new flash rebirth comic while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Game of Thrones hype
Q&A get hype and you can click here to
learn all about legends of tomorrow
season to Justice Society and vixen
coming on the show she's going to be a
series regular so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight